18:53 and the Americans are here where
Japan why to open up the country the man
leading the American expedition was a
certain Commodore Matthew Perry who
essentially told the Japanese to allow
American imports or face war for the
previous 200 years Japan had been closed
to all foreigners under the pain of
death because as far as the Japanese
were concerned foreigners were a tad
meddlesome the orders to close the
borders had come from the bakufu also
known as the Shogun at the bakufu was
the central government of Japan which
was led by a Shogun who lived in Edo
technically he was appointed by the
Emperor who lived in Kyoto but frankly
the Emperor was just a puppet Japan at
this point was very decentralized with
regional daimyo able to set their own
tax rates
it was also undergoing a period of major
economic stagnation and there were
social tensions bubbling away under the
surface inflation and famine swept the
countryside and many were noticing the
increased wealth of the merchant class
despite them being at the bottom of the
social hierarchy it was within the
context of this period of tension that
the Americans had arrived and they
pledged to return a year later to hear
the Japanese response
apparently Commodore Perry can't wait
that long and so returned about six
months later this time with more ships
and the Japanese signed a treaty to
allow trade and soon after that the
British arrived and gained a similar
deal by 1858 Japan had established
formal relations and trading agreements
with the US Britain the Russian Empire
the Netherlands and France these
concessions to foreign powers made the
bakufu look weak there were major splits
among Japan's daimyo about how to
respond to outside threats to make
things worse the Shogun was also dying
and then there had to be selected so in
order to promote unity the chief counsel
of the bukuvu hata Masayoshi asked the
emperor komai to give his approval to
the trade deals and the Shogun's air
well the emperor said no and hatta
resigned in shame sometime yo such as
that of cho see rallied against the
Shogun by 1866 japan was in crisis the
new Shogun Yoshinobu attempted to crush
tofu and to restore order but was
defeated when the daimyo of Satsuma
refused to help the bakufu's defeat led
chozo and Satsuma to march on kyoto
which they captured in 1867 whilst there
the new emperor meiji announced the
restoration of the emperor as the ruler
of japan this kick-started what is known
as the potion war which the Shogunate
quickly lost
this was coincided with the
modernization of Japanese military
tactics and both sides had received help
from the West
having been victorious and premiu moved
from Kyoto to Edo which was renamed
Tokyo from where he would run Japan
over the next couple of decades the
imperial government began the process of
nation-building such as by building a
new shrine in Tokyo for Japan's war dead
and by dismantling the social
hierarchies of the past the late 19th
century also saw the creation of Japan's
first political parties who argued over
important new issues such as
representation or whether or not Korea
should be immediately invaded the
Japanese military went through a period
of reform as well for a start Japan now
had a national military which fought
under one flag at first it consisted
exclusively of samurai but was reformed
by 3rd marshal Yamagata era Tomo who
introduced national conscription for all
men over 20 also during the closing
decades of the 19th century Japan
underwent a period of massive
industrialization railway started to
spring up from 1872 alongside numerous
textile factories much of which was paid
for by the state of course the state had
ever expenses such as paying off samurai
who up until this point received an
annual payment from the local daimyo
this payment called a stipend was
carried over to the new imperial
government and was very expensive
needless to say the government spending
almost half of its income paying a bunch
of samurai was controversial and
beginning in 1871 the government started
to phase it out so the samurai at this
point were becoming quite upset they
were no longer at the top of the social
structure stopped receiving free money
and weren't even seen as the Honorable
defenders of Japan since any old peasant
could join the army now this resentment
led to the Satsuma rebellion of 1877
which the new conscript army was able to
crush quite handily the major changes
Japan underwent during the second half
of the 19th century culminated in the
1889 constitution this constitution
created a western-style government with
a prime minister who served under the
emperor and with an elected lower house
although the vast majority of men and no
women could vote culture at this time
also underwent massive changes and the
people of Japan had the difficult task
to define what it meant to be Japanese
the government attempted to aid the
creation of a Japanese identity through
the new education system this alongside
conscription was used to promote and
foster a shared sense of identity so
Japan quickly found itself becoming an
ambitious modern nation-state and what
was the one thing that all the great
nation states that the world had at this
point they had empires which meant Japan
wanted one too this kick-started a
period of imperial expansion in 1875
Japan took the riyuku Island the
best-known being Okinawa after that
Japan turned inside to Korea which at
this point was a puppet of China so
people like era Tomo Korea was going to
be conquered eventual
so it may as well have been by Japan at
first using some good old-fashioned
gunboat diplomacy the Japanese signed
their own treaty with Korea eventually
the Japanese presence in Korea led to
what is known as the donghak rebellion
this massively destabilized Korea and so
both Japan and China sent troops in to
protect their interest
these troops clashed and thus begun the
first sino-japanese war because of the
modernization of the military as well as
a huge naval budda the Japanese
thoroughly stomped the Chinese as a
result Korea formally entered Japan
sphere of influence in Japan also seized
Taiwan China also seated here the
liaodong peninsula but after threats
from Russia Japan gave it up Japan
wanted to be seen by Westerners as their
equal this didn't happen despite the
fact that Japan actually provided the
most troops and ships for the
eight-nation alliance which put down the
Boxer Rebellion in China between 1899
and 1902 the Boxer Rebellion was
essentially an uprising designed to
remove foreigners from China but these
countries intervened and eventually the
rebellion was crushed
the long-term effects with the Europeans
were less meddlesome in China except for
Russia who took the opportunity to seize
Manchuria so the only European country
that took Japan seriously was Britain
who in 1902 entered an alliance with
them importantly Britain became the
first Western nation to acknowledge the
Japanese claim to Korea in 1905 Japan
sought similar acknowledgement from
Russia which they refused in response
they launched a sneak attack against the
Russian fleet in Port Arthur thus
starting the 1905 russo-japanese war in
which the Russians were firmly defeated
as a result Japan came this territory
and Russia agreed to leave Manchuria
very little happened in the next decade
unless you were Emperor Meiji because
that was when you died or unless you
were Korea because that was when you
were annexed in 1914 Britain called
Japan into world war one which Japan
used as an excuse to grab all of these
German territories it also used the
chaos to wish you the twenty-one demands
to China
these were rejected and eventually only
thirteen of these demands were agreed
upon Japan gained influence over
Manchuria but it sowed the vision
between Japan and Britain as well as
upsetting the United States for its help
during the war Japan was invited to join
in drafting the Treaty of Versailles and
in establishing the League of Nations
Japan asked for the league to consider
all races as equal this was rejected
formally by the Americans but it was
mostly because of Britain since it would
have meant that Britain had to consider
its colonial subjects as equals which
wasn't going to happen in 1920 Britain
abandoned the anglo-japanese alliance in
the next year alongside the United
States
can beat the Washington Naval conference
this sought to limit the number of large
ships each country's Navy could have
with only Britain and the United States
being allowed the most the next year
things wouldn't get much better for
Japan due to a major earthquake which
killed 150 thousand people
furthermore the Japanese economy
collapsed in the military became much
more influential in politics in 1926
emprah show are better known in the West
as Emperor Hirohito
ascended the throne and his reign saw
the continued growth of Emperor worship
on September the 18th 1931 a detachment
of the Japanese Army in Manchuria
attempted to destroy a piece of railway
they blame Chinese rebels and this was
used as pretext for invasion and by
February the next year Manchuria was a
Japanese puppet state this was condemned
by the League of Nations and in response
Japan withdrew isolating itself the Army
in Japan was becoming more ambitious and
in 1936 there was even an attempted coup
by one of its factions this was crushed
by the Emperor who had given his support
to another faction but either way the
military was effectively in control of
Japan's government the army wanted to
further expand Japanese power and this
led to what is known as the Marco Polo
Bridge incident in 1937 where Japanese
and Chinese troops exchanged fire the
new prime minister fumimaro konoe ii who
was originally appointed to rein in the
army authorized an invasion within a few
months the Japanese had advanced all the
way to Nanjing where the infamous
Nanjing Massacre occurred whereby tens
of thousands of civilians were raped and
murdered in 1941 the United States and a
Franklin D Roosevelt began an oil
embargo against Japan Japan refused to
back down to what they saw as America
meddling and on December the 7th 1941
launched the infamous attack on Pearl
Harbor which saw 4,000 American
casualties compared to Japan 65 at the
same time Japanese forces attacked the
British colonies of Malaya Singapore and
Hong Kong initially Japan did very well
winning major victories over the
European powers notably the Battle of
Singapore in 1942 which saw 80,000
British soldiers surrender by mid-1942
Japan held all of this territory but its
advances were stolen because it was too
much territory to hold many of the
European territory seized by the
Japanese had puppet governments
installed importantly these governments
were run by the native peoples there
which helped spur an independent
movements even after the war Japanese
luck began to change when the American
strategy of island hopping as well as
some major naval defeat such as the
Battle of Midway in the Battle of Leyte
Gulf from in the
and could no longer adequately project
power by the time the war in Europe was
over Japan had been pushed back all the
way to here and on August the 6th 1945
the United States dropped an atomic bomb
on the city of Hiroshima and three days
later another one on the city of
Nagasaki killing an estimated 150,000
people on September the 2nd Japan
formally surrendered to the Allied
forces and was occupied by the United
States the Americans find that's the
period of reconstruction and a new
constitution was completed in 1947 which
still holds today and it famously
prevents Japan from declaring war in
conclusion the Meiji Restoration saw the
birth of a truly unified Japan this
Japan was a victim of many humiliations
by Western powers who despite Japan's
achievements refused to see as an equal
the close relationship between military
and politics in Japan led to an
expansionist state whose ambitions or
even attacked the United States a
decision that would ultimately lead to
its destruction it should also be noted
that the Japanese occupation of many
European colonies was the catalyst for
those colonies seeking their own
independence in the following decades I
hope you enjoyed this episode and thank
you for watching